hello
i'm paul carling with film independent
and welcome to this week's coffee talk
for those of you who don't know us film
independent is the non-profit
la based arts organization that produces
the film independent spirit awards plus
hundreds of
yearly screenings conversations
workshops and filmmaker labs
you can find out more about us at
filmindependent.org
now this week we're joined by two
celebrated filmmakers who are much more
than just
writer directors uh first up she's an
actor
screenwriter director and performance
artist uh
writing directing credits include butter
on the latch
the spirit award nominated madeline's
madeline and the show
room 104 for the duplass brothers our
latest film
is shirley based on the life or a few
months
in the life of acclaimed writer shirley
jackson who's the author of course of
the morning of hill house and the
lottery and many others uh shirley is
now streaming on hulu
uh it's a pleasure to welcome josephine
decker to the coffee talks hi jeff
thank you so much for having me paul i'm
so glad to be here and get to talk to
you miranda too
this is such a pleasure i'm like love it
and obviously
very very big fan of film independent
and how much they're supporting
independent film you're joining us from
texas you said yes i'm in dallas
and is it is and trying to stay cool
there
we're trying yes it is i think it was
like 105 degrees here yesterday so
um i i i i went actually went for a jog
and it turned out that was it wasn't it
you know i just haven't left the house
today
at all so that's the aftermath yeah
and uh all joining josephine is another
multi-multi-hyphenate
uh an artist an author a singer an actor
screenwriter and director i've probably
left a few other things out there
her debut feature me and you and
everyone we know i won the camera door
at cannes film festival and was
nominated for two spirit awards
uh as an author she's known for her
short stories including
collection no one belongs here more than
you her latest film cajillionaire played
sundance earlier this year
and will be released uh in september
we're thrilled to have with us
around july hi miranda hi
how are you doing i'm all right yeah
i see one night right i'm here in l.a
yeah in in echo park um
see if this was a live audience i'd say
echo park and then a few people would go
like whoa
people could raise their hands and we
could see it right
yeah or they'd say echo echo
that wouldn't happen only in like our
poetic
version of that oh there's larkin's race
people are raising their hands
it's funny two five five people
work you guys
you seven people could all just like
come over
and say yeah anyways i miss people
in in this setting i don't so much when
i'm just alone
writing here but um i did
i did love an audience
[Laughter]
later on ask the audience listening in
to
submit some questions we'll get to their
questions later on as a q a button at
the bottom of the screen you can use
that
um i'm curious if anyone wants to raise
their hands
uh as a shout out for texas oh yeah
dallas does anyone
from i would be very surprised
wait three people raised a hand well i
think two of those were left
so i would count oh they were left over
okay you know
okay but we have two people you had to
raise that wow
okay that's good to know that's amazing
that's so cool
kelly brianna okay amazing thanks guys
we're look dallas has an amazing all you
know
in indie film scene actually so maybe
you'll find out a bit it's a very it's a
very
cool later on uh so yeah the way this
works is i'm going to step off this
virtual stage and let the two of you
chat and kind of talk filmmakery shot
talk for about half an hour and i'll be
back
with some questions in about 30 minutes
all right thanks paul
hi miranda the scary thing about
is like it's like
the thing about an audience is it sort
of keeps you remembering that there is
an audience
whereas this is so much like it's just
you and me
that um we have to really watch
who had that fear i i was very much
having that fear i was like
i should not ask about this i should not
talk about that yeah
yeah we have to keep the friends things
friendly
yeah i totally i i know exactly what you
mean how are you
um yeah i'm all right
right now i uh
you know it's definitely up and down but
i think a lot of my mood depends on
if i mean always in my life but
especially now like if i'm able to do my
creative work just enough you know
then it's like my chin's above the water
and i can be
like a generous person
in other areas of my life you know and
and um uh but i get kind of
it's so easy for that to just go away
like there's not very
much time and then yes something comes
up and i'm promoting this movie and
whatever
and it doesn't happen and then you have
this kind of starved
robbed yes feeling you know and
um i i mean
such is life in general yeah yeah but
today was like i just
achieved you know this if you remember i
spend wednesday nights alone
in my studio i spend the night okay um
and so
thursday morning it's really designed so
that i can wake up alone
on thursday and write um
but wednesday nights can be kind of wild
for me creatively
um too like i get a little because i'm
just here
alone for once and so that was nice
you're catching me on the end of that
yeah is the
does that's amazing actually that's this
is a smart
tactic because the creative flow sort of
requires isolation and
we both have a child and that makes it
it's
it's just a different i have i have
definitely
my my relationship to my creativity has
changed since having her in
a beautiful way but it's just it's also
like i mean partly i just care about it
less
i think i've been doing i think i've
been being creative my whole life
because i wanted love
and now i have it
i mean i feel like i doubled down
at that point or something so that's so
interesting i mean that must
that's good that must feel good i think
it does feel good exactly i was noticing
that as i was looking at like your
website and being like how is she
this prolific like how how how and
that makes sense that you would have
doubled down and i think it does force
you to structure the time actually
half of my questions are like how does
she do all this
what how does she structure her time so
i'm glad that we have an insight now
to the wednesday evenings
oh what were you gonna say yes please go
into that i was just going to ask you
more specific
time questions make me specific yeah
do you so cause i was really i've been
admiring how you use instagram as i
think of it as a part of your art
practice
and um i have i've i think i
admire it also because i feel like i
have such a block about social media i
sort of feel like i live in the 1500s
and
i just grew up on like novels and like
tarkovsky and so i have a really hard
time wrapping my head around like how to
interface with an audience that i
can't see and that i don't know you know
and and
you do it so elegantly and you and you
and i think maybe i don't know and it
seems like you do get to know them
through the process of making your art
and i was curious how you take like if
you
dedicate a certain time to that part of
your practice or if it sort of just
flows
out of your natural organization of your
day
like how do you organize your day well i
mean
i think the thing also is like
it just happens that my brain has always
been
interested in whatever the technology
even when the technology was just the
p.o box
you know i was like wow what everything
you could do with the us postal system
you know and that's like when i started
joni for jackie big mr wheeler and then
it was like
a website like how could that be art
even though people
you know at that point people thought of
it as like a business tool
you know at the beginning yes and then
like
or like an app like ooh what so that's
already
like i think i'm actually not that
great at instagram i remember my
new publicist saying to me like
yes it will be interesting to see if
you're able to use it to promote
your work not
i mean she's very smart she just was a
little bit calling my
you know like it's not exactly the same
thing what i'm doing
as being a really skillful like
whatever so yeah what comes naturally to
me and that i
i just have ideas in the same as any
other medium is sort of like
right how can how can this be useful to
do
like there's something i've been trying
to do as far as like
a very organic spontaneous kind of
filmmaking that i've been trying to do
my whole life
and like just recently i understood
how instagram live
could really connect filmmaking and
performance
um in a way that hasn't been possible
before and since i
do both of those things and love both of
those things and
and often you know like for a while i
was trying to like make a movie
in a museum you know which was so i
guess as like an artwork
with yes you know these ideas you know
so many of which
i never achieved but i didn't let go of
it and so a new medium comes along and
i'm like
wait wait wait that idea oh that would
be so easy with this the
infrastructure's
already there and it's so cheap so
but as far as the like actual
you know like promoting this talk like i
didn't do
you know it's um i did promote it
um but i don't um
i think i mostly just try and think a
little bit about
how bored how dead we all are and i try
and think of like what's one little
thing i could do
to make it a little more yeah sticky or
whatever
but you know you're um
you're like a a true filmmaker you know
what i mean like you
i really am thinking like in a lot of
different mediums and i'm always sort of
like when you when i heard through the
grapevine that you were
shooting i'm allowed to say that you're
shooting next month
yeah i think so yeah i think right yeah
i probably should have checked with
someone but yes we're shooting next
month yes i was like
so shocked you know like kind of aghast
i was like wait weren't we just at
sundance with our new movies how
is how she and i was like okay right
like if i had started another move you
know if all these projects
that i'm doing that um are books or
you know or whatever for a movie like
because i have to reassure myself
because it seems
so hardcore to me you know like
that's i love that miranda i literally
went through such like uh
like a a mel like it was i mean it
wasn't it was just a meltdown
i had it transformed but i was like i
don't know miranda is just
she's she's a superhero and i don't know
how she lives on earth like
she's done so much and like you know
like a little bit of an inferiority
complex being like i can't believe
she's done all of these things and then
i was like my god she's a goddess
like all you can do is just say thank
you thank you for this pers
and you can't put yourself okay you
can't be like i should be as productive
as miranda because there's no
that's just not even a um we read
between the lines of my text yesterday
i was like like
hardcore processing like be a good
friend to your friend
don't just have your own issues about
how you probably won't make another
movie for years
like cheer her on like support your
friend
it's not about you i feel like i did a
pretty good job given that i was like
being triggered like
right and left i am
i just yeah i so appreciate you saying
that because
literally i could not have been more of
a similar experience like i'm looking at
your
instagram looking at your website i'm
like i she's made like 20 art projects
in the last like
like four months like every every day
she makes a new art project
and i know that you're working on like
multiple like
films that i don't even know if they've
even come to the fruition like
you know like you you have a lot yeah i
mean i guess one thing i look at
that's different about us is
making movies to me really still seems
like
going to the moon like it's so intense
and scary and i feel like i have to
leave my
family and it's it's not organic
at all to me whereas a lot of the other
things i do
i don't i'm a little less scared of you
know
and i feel like you don't have that like
yeah yeah i like i know that from being
on set with you
like you don't like
i'm pretty sure if you ask my actors
they'll be like oh yeah
she thinks she's on the moon like
it's like she's like
freaking she's so honored and freaking
the [ __ ] out and think she might die and
you know like
everything's at like 10 which is i don't
know maybe it makes it sort of exciting
and important
it's not like the hell you know um
you know like you actually are chill
um i try very hard to be chill yeah i do
i remember you saying this thing
uh like you talking about
remember the play-doh like that kind of
play-doh
like if you want an actor to do
something i thought this might be useful
for this audience what's that kind of
play-doh that corn starch
it was like with cornstarch yes i
remember learning this
yeah about teenagers actually they
taught this to me when i
say that i just want to make sure to get
that tidbit in for our director
audience yeah when i was teaching summer
camp they said like
you know teenagers are like this they've
mixed cornstarch and water and it was
like if you push
hard it hardens like it hardens and it
and it
it will like create a barrier to you and
then
but if you just gently slowly softly you
know it will just
give laughs and that's that's definitely
um i do try a lot do a lot of gently
slowly softly with everybody you know
but then that's also about though like
trying to get other people's
best ideas you know not not to put my
own idea
first i always try to like create a
space where
many ideas can arise and that everyone
feels like their idea
is is as important as you know my idea
you know but then ultimately i have to
have the confidence that
they understand that i didn't always
have this confidence
it's gotten better over time that that
ultimately i am the director
it took me a long time to figure that
out um because sometimes i would float
all the ideas and then i'd be like oh
i don't want to do my idea more than
anyone else's and how do i
let everyone know that
yeah this is so interesting because i'm
thinking about
um recently
uh mike like we're both also married to
directors
um our partners are you guys married um
we're partnered
i'm not married but yes my partner's
yeah yeah yeah
uh mike and i were looking at um
sort of uh like
white supremacist language and and
hierarchies and
workplaces you know which kind of white
supremacist is not in the nazi sense but
in the sense that like our entire
country is yes that way all the systems
are
and we were going through the list and
we were like huh
um like the first step is is just
acknowledging like yes this
is a um
this workplace is designed
hierarchically
you know acknowledging what it really is
and seeing what it is yes
and we were just kind of like laughing
but
also crying seeing like right our
our workplace is like the opposite
of non-violent communication if the
obvious
this is like that's what you're talking
about and i guess
um i'm interest
i i'm so interested in that um like
did have you actually consciously
thought of that um you know i didn't i
didn't
the well it's what i realized a little
bit recently was that um
i have for a long time my tactic as a
leader has been to like
reduce my own sense of authority reduce
the sense of my authority
in front of other people so that people
do not feel intimidated by me scared by
me or that i am
actually the like that they feel safe to
know that they're in good hands
and that the hands i don't know i mean
this is like i don't
this sounds like i don't know whatever
i'll just but that you know that
that ideally that that um there's a
safety of vulnerability and failure
which is part of the process and the
fact of like that i don't know
everything feels like an important thing
for everyone to really understand
going into it so that their own not
knowing which is usually
to me the most interesting part of
performance or
camera work is like when you get into a
space of not knowing
is actually when things get really
exciting and interesting and
and you start to see images or
performances that you haven't really
seen before because the actor
hasn't conceived of it before this
moment they're being present you know so
um trying to like create a space of that
and i do i didn't ever do it i mean i
guess it was probably conscious but it
was very subconscious because i think
i'm just like that like i'm
i'm afraid of everyone i don't want i
like
don't want to hurt anyone's feelings and
so i don't know you know it came
naturally and then it's so funny
i took like an acting class or directing
class
and they were like this is how you
should do it and i was like oh that's
that's
kind of what i've been doing that's
great i don't know anyway
i want to just say like for our audience
if this was like if we were on stage i
would turn to the audience and i would
be like
this is why we want diversity
in terms of different kinds of voices
telling the stories it's not for some
there's there's not uh you know
it's not to fulfill some quota or
something like that
like you're you're going about it really
differently
um and it's making different kinds of
movies
and the people working on the movies are
having different experiences
you know and they're taking those
experiences into their lives and their
families
i know i did you know i acted in your
moving and it it changed my life
um and uh i
i just i just want to stop and like
there's just that
um we are so
robbed of that uh when we don't
when everyone um is
is believing in the same kind of heart
hierarchy and
and i and there's a lot more um
in this you know part of why this this
medium is challenging for me or
intimidating is
there is a sense of that there is a way
to do it you know probably
you know one reason why some people are
logged on to this is because it's like
wait how do you do this and in other
mediums
there really is um
you know like the idea of that you would
be taught writing is a little negligible
you know like
people generally think like create a
creative writing class is like a little
bit of a cheesy idea even if
you know they're still valuable but
that's not with filmmaking it's really
like there's this credentialism this you
know not only do you need to know the
way but you have to be able to cite the
references behind your work
and i um
i really uh i want to
i want to work against that that said i
think
in my actual filmmaking practice
as far as me on set maybe not um
creatively or the ideas themselves i
don't think but me on set i think i'm
um i'm less radical than you
uh because
because i'm less relaxed in a way you
know
well you know it's i was noticing when i
was watching your movie which is so
it's so fun to see the final product
because i had seen a couple rough cuts
and i
saw it's just i mean it's so beautiful
miranda and so
like special and absolutely unusual and
and i also was like oh my gosh we have
the opposite process like
you're a writer and you craft everything
before you shoot
and i came from documentary and like
love the concept of discovering the
movie in the edit which is not something
that
is really supposed to be allowed in
fiction films i think like people
like the whole reason they do the script
thing and they're like and then like
everyone
like gives a million notes on the
scripts and then like studios approve
the script is that
that's supposed to be how you make a
movie and then um
right but i but somehow i don't know it
managed to work it out but but i really
felt like
the other thing is that it's you you
write you do
do that more maybe more standard you're
very making pretty much
writing yeah when you're writing but the
writing is so
wild i mean it's like way it's magical
every there's a million details that are
like
shocking like the the i mean so this is
i guess this audience maybe some people
have seen the film from sundance
um maybe maybe from sundance um
but um there's like the actors have
synchronized watches which is just
something that like
i don't know it's it and it shows up
so many perfect to get better than that
you guys
i mean there are a million things that
are but that's the kind of small detail
it just makes it punctuates the film in
these like
hilarious ways and then and evan rachel
would
oh my god i just i think you know it's
so funny because when the first
i've seen it three times now the first
time i took in the film
you're taking so much because there's so
many you're learning a world you're
learning a whole language that you've
like created
for this film to be and then this time i
really just was like i cannot believe
how amazing her performance is i mean
she is just it's so vulnerable and
intense and like absolutely unlike
anything i've ever seen before
and i remembered that in the first two
times i watched it
i just thought oh what a what an ugly
girl you know
like like that she had just like that my
my really my real intense experience was
of the character
it was of like this person that you just
you were like what a weird person i
don't i don't know if i would want to be
around that person
like in a great way like you achieved
the goal for the character and then it
was only this time that i was like there
is a performer inside of there who is
one of the most beautiful women
on earth like doing the most
unnervingly bizarre
excitingly uh kind of like
um uh
harsh slash vulnerable things you could
imagine it's just so anyway you did a
beautiful job of like creating that
character and working with her and i
mean
there's a million things i love about
your movie and that one was particularly
flooring
to me on this watching yeah thank you
yeah it is we what i
i too saw your movie in a rougher form
and then just
recently finished and it's because of
that thing that you
i mean i love editing too but i remember
you saying to me once
like i said something about well how do
you know something's gonna cut
together if you're going about it in
that way and you're like oh i can make
anything cut
and i was like oh okay that's a
like i feel like i can write anything
but i don't have that level of fit you
know like you really
are an editor and i i yeah
we you know watching the movie finished
i was like
oh jesus she like
she just like i you
you made it better and better up until
the last you know like you added it's
like you're painting or something
and you're just so free and you added
all these things like i i
i thought i was just gonna be looking
for like did you leave this in or out
and i was like oh no you were like and
i'm gonna add a little more light there
and a little
make it a little creepier here and it
was and i was like wow
it sort of makes sense why you would
give me the notes like you were one of
the last people to give me notes
on kajillionaire and they were super
useful
but i also understand them better now
thinking like
oh from your point of view it's never
too late
you know like you can i know i remember
them being like
like what i can't remember what the
notes were at all but i i remember them
not being like not necessarily they were
like easy like oh just
it was like maybe put this scene earlier
or something like
that they were they like kind of forced
me to go
deep again which is
um yeah which is like i think a place
you're able to just like
live um i don't know in that process
i don't know it's endlessly i mean the
audience should know that josephine and
i have
had this conversation many times where
we're like if i could just have a pinch
of what you have
you know then i would be like a
perfect filmmaker right you know like
because it's like i do think and we have
fantasized about working together
like more so you know i would still like
to do
yeah because i do think it's too
right i well good okay good i'm so glad
that door is opening
thank you this is really this has been
my dream for a long time in fact i got
to
meet lena dunham um okay who i just
talked to her about that
but thanks to you know partly thanks to
you know the fact that you had
introduced her to my work i think
you know when we made madeline's
madeline and um uh
and we were talking about how wonderful
of an actor you are and how
we both just want to make you to put you
in everything
so oh you're really the only two people
so
i could say yes to both of them
and you too it's funny i just talked to
her after you did
um and and i said you know
when people ask me like what's different
in terms of being like a woman filmmaker
now
compared to when you started out the
difference is the two of you like
i have ambitions to have other
friends who are women filmmakers like i
see them out there and you know the
pandemic has slowed me down a little bit
but you two are the first real friends
like where you could talk about
sex and your relationships and then move
into like casting and
because um imagine for my whole life
before
you know when my close close friends
would ask me about work and i was making
a movie i'd be like uh
yeah yeah i want you to say it's like
that um it's just nuts right i mean
um it isn't it's very accessible you
know
or relatable or you know why the stakes
are so high
you know yes like it yeah
but you know it's interesting because i
was thinking about as i was looking at
all of your work and about and like the
curtains piece where
um just to give a little context for
those of you watching randa made a piece
well you should probably tell because i
was like you're gonna try and describe
this
should you want me to i'll give it two
seconds version
i don't know you don't want me to okay
well anyway
it's a very complex piece that's um
where uh
a man that miranda got to be got to know
his sleep patterns and internet patterns
were related in curtains that would open
and close whether he was like a sleeper
awake and he was an
uber driver who was also sort of
homeless um
uh i mean it was like went through
phases maybe and um
uh but they became close friends my
sense was and then
um but uh why am i talking about this
piece
i i was like i needed to give context
and now i'm like what
was i gonna say oh well just but i i was
so impressed by your
your this way of like collapsing ideas
like you're like okay it's
gonna be a museum but i'm gonna take
this very personal
unique experience interaction i had with
one person while he was my uber
driver and like translate it via
internet capabilities
you just mashed up so many media and i
it really
got me thinking like how does miranda
have
these ideas i mean and who are your
who are the people that you go to like
when you're like i need to have a
brilliant idea or or just when you have
off time and you're like i'm going to go
to the place i always go for inspiration
where is that place um
i it's everywhere it's basically
evernote um like which is just to say
that it's more that
like as with you i mean we talked about
this like ideas can come at
any time and really i think i'm just
very i'm like superstitious about
writing them down you know even if it's
like
i'm in the middle of making a movie i'm
obviously not gonna do that anytime soon
but i have sort of like a bank almost
that's very comforting to me like i
don't have
a lot of money but i have these ideas um
and some of them don't play out for
years but i return to them and and
sometimes it'll be just a little
piece like omaru when i met him from day
one that i met him he was like you have
to tell my story somehow and i'm like
well i'm not a journalist you know
but we you know went ahead and we're
friends for years
um and i even worked quite hard on that
project before i realized it could be
about
him like i was trying to make it about
all these other people
and there was a sort of a time zone
issue and i was like it has to be
someone in la
so that i'm awake
when it's um because it was in london
the piece and then i was like
awake in the middle of the night who do
i know
that has insomnia like really bad
and that's how i came to that you know
and i was like just
that had broken my heart that he had
ptsd
from being illegal and worrying about
you know immigration coming you know
like that had obviously stuck
couldn't deal with it really at the time
but you know things just
come up um yeah
so i think it's like that um
are there other artists that you
love or that you have like that you feel
like
oh they're kind of doing something like
that i
am down with yeah i think
um like sophie call
you know her work yes um i mean a lot of
times it's someone who's more squarely
in the art world and i'm yeah
not really um but i think those are the
kind of people who sort of give me
room who seem really freeing at their
practice it is true that it's less often
a filmmaker or a writer you know because
um not i mean not that i'm not inspired
by them but when
but i career-wise it's like harder for
me to
yeah you know it makes me anxious like
when i look at you
and i'm like [ __ ] i'm moving in slow
motion like
she's so much younger than me but you
know um so
it calms me down in a way to look at uh
people whose yeah yeah
it's coming that way are we about to
turn into audience questions oh right
all right good point um
i guess oh wait i have one
i have one can i have one more thought
it's more of a thought note
than anything i have like i have like
literally this i have a million
questions that i was gonna ask you but i
they're i think there's not a time but
one crazy thing thought that i did have
was that so one of the defining aspects
of shirley
shirley jackson's actual writing um
was is this duality of female characters
like her
a lot of her stories and novels have
this like one female character who's
very misanthropic
who's like kind of like um
uh very vulnerable and insecure but also
sometimes like expresses things like
wickedly
or
very comedic and super great wit and
then the other
is some someone who's like good at
baking and like a really excellent
um uh like gets along well with men
and has social skills and that this is a
really defining part of shirley
jackson's a lot of her writing is like
that
in a way and um and these women are very
comple
also complex but they have they have to
sort of fit into those
kind of those two types um and then i
was like when i was watching your movie
and i was like this is a movie about
in a way two women who are very
similarly
and you and also in the first bad man i
was like there's kind of a theme that
miranda has in her work of these two
different women
like one very very like in a way like
sexualized
being right who um is maybe trapped in
that sexualized
notion of herself and then one who's um
really considers herself like way more
uh
or is presents much more maybe like
strangely yeah yeah yeah
i know i think that you know
how sometimes you'll have two works that
you think are
made from the same time
they're from the same time roughly in
your life so like i do think
i mean i you know i noticed i think at
one point i was like oh [ __ ] did i just
make the same thing twice
but that's not true at all but you know
i think a lot of artists
probably yeah have that do kind of
accidentally keep
making the same thing yeah um
you yeah well there was more i mean i
think both
i think you feel very different it was
more like uh at least because i've read
shirley's biography and they talk a lot
about like her
having you know the these this is there
are
two parts of one consciousness and like
that she's trying to reconcile this like
that she is maybe part the part of the
really great mother and great
baker and part is like misanthropic and
and sort of like wants to kill
her family
yeah i mean i think
like our best conversations i think are
where we
like allow each other room to say the
things that are
completely contradictory to everything
we're
seeming to want to do with our lives you
know yeah
um and that's those things are real and
just as
just as real and true and if they can't
come out things are going to go
badly at some point you know and i think
often um like a
female friendship like is the first safe
space to be like
oh and by the way i also
i can't say the whole the things yeah
yeah they also
feel the opposite of this you know yes
and then you begin to embody that maybe
next through your work
and then next like in your life in a
small way and then in a bigger you know
like
i do think there's something
um it's like if filmmaking is part of
the process of living having
like a friendship that encompasses that
also really kind of um makes it all
feel like it's kind of like
earthy i mean to be honest like kind of
like you're a living
thing you're not with these sort of
productive segments you know
like um like you're
like a growing thing yes yeah
um so you're
that's thank you well that's i mean i'm
i'm i
i it's funny because i was asking you
abstractly about your characters
but i think it sounds like what you're
saying is that
in your real life your female
friendships are
a source that is feeding
your work in a way i guess i'm saying i
think i am
both those women always you know yeah
and that's pretty hard
it's pretty uncomfortable it's not
really allowed one of them is always
totally illegal
for what's going on and
one way i contain that is in my work but
also
in my like closed friendships because
it's like a safe place
to say that but fiction is too you know
yeah wow okay thanks
thanks paul thanks for letting me go
into my heady
interpretations
uh you have time for some questions yeah
they're they're they're trickling in so
uh there's a
anonymous uh question here asking about
your
working relationship on madeleine's
mandolin and
uh josephine like working with miranda
as a friend
and as an actor and miranda working
just seeing josephine's process how she
directed can you talk about
that for anonymous here yeah
can i go first um oh yeah
cause i i did i
said yes to the invitation um of
acting and playing this part in this
movie i did it
entirely i mean i thought at the time
although i think i had maybe had various
unconscious reasons but to see how
josephine worked as a director because
it's very mysterious when you watch your
movies
um how they are made and so i was like
at least i'll get to know um and i
thought that would serve me as a
director and i
actually um after i was done i
um came home and wrote a list of what i
had learned
and what not to forget
the next one um let's see where oh yeah
it says it's called read before and
during the shoot
this was like to myself um the shoot of
kajillionaire really
um but i mean i won't read the whole
list
uh but the first thing on
it um is nothing is worth
losing the trust and connection of an
actor you lose that and you could lose
the whole movie
um and i think i
yeah i just saw that being the i mean of
course it seems like a no-brainer right
you know but i think
directors get freaked out or whatever
they use their
power in relationship to their anxiety
in weird ways and even if you do it in a
little tiny way like
actors are so sensitive you know
like that's why you hired them it's
because they're like
alien-like and their sensitivity so it
could just be like
the subtlest thing that you can't even
really be held accountable for
that you did that was like passive
aggressive or something i don't know
i mean and uh and
anyways i just thought the way that that
was like clear above all else and it's
easy
to do most of the time you really are
just
cherishing these people you know but
it's also hard work you know it's it's
incredibly
hard exhausting job so that was i don't
know i would just
there's a whole list of them i should
like sell this but
they're just you you know they're just
me noticing you um but
that yeah and some of it is really
uh really
just practical um
uh
um like if you're angry about
something like i saw sometimes i think
you being a little angry or unnerved by
something and just really using humor
and sometimes even like joking about
what you were stressed about
you know in this way that kind of like
everyone can feel the stress like we're
losing our day
you know like that is abundantly clear
that things are not going well you know
so like to just sort of let everyone in
on it
yeah like such a gift that everyone can
just be like
yeah wow we're really going to hell
right this
second can you believe it you know and
then it turns and it's always turning on
a dime on a set right like
yeah end of the day you're like i can't
believe we did that we all pulled
together right at the end and we got it
and yeah
wow that was you know and you made that
possible with like
keeping it not in a false way but like
making those pivots like keeping it kind
of agile
like that never like hunkering down and
doing all the [ __ ] up human stuff
people can do
under pressure okay you go that's true
i i yeah no that's i yeah i try to yeah
it's funny i i do remember breathing a
lot especially on shirley i just
remember breathing a lot
um because it was very stressful yeah
but then you
then i was like i can't hold on if i
hold on to any of this
i will stop being able to make a good
movie so i just have to like constantly
let everything go
i meditated like every morning it was
somehow different
madeline's madeline was um so much
harder no i mean they were
both hard every movie is too hard
they're hard it's really hard
um uh well it's interesting because
you know my experience working with you
was uh
i mean well it's so fun that we got our
little process ahead of time and then we
got to have
um i think we worked on a few scenes
together
ahead of time and it was very clear like
i was like why don't we try just
improvising a little bit around these
scenes and you
were so amazing i mean what i had
written
was so you know like peace
to your like you know apple crumble
it was like this magical you just you
you and and i think almost every
scene that you have in the film almost
all of them
we there was some level of improvisation
that you're really and
everyone's everyone sees the movie and
they're like so you improvise the whole
movie and i'm like actually it's
all scripted except miranda who
but it's because you you're just you're
a terrific storyteller you can
you add so much and you understand so
quickly
and it's so like every other aspect of
your work
you know that you have this nuance with
details where you
can bring in these very specific details
and make the character more
more specific more themselves you know
the freckles like you talk
you know talking about molly parker's
freckles as like god i hope she work you
know
whatever she worries about those those
freckles you know and
um yeah yeah it's like
writing is sort of my sweet spot
then it is very tied to acting for me
and so the fact that you let
me in like that
was a very smart move as a as a director
too
because like that was where i was gonna
feel
best you know and therefore essentially
sort of give you what you needed
it was great well it was so much fun i
mean it made it so fun
and also the other thing that you know
really stuck out was
how i mean there were many things but
you were incredibly supportive
i mean i think often my job as a
director i think is mostly trying to
help the actors feel
safe and comfortable and you were
constantly checking on me actually and
you were constantly like how are you
doing
are you you know are you okay because
you understood how challenging it is to
kind of hold all the pieces and so i
really
appreciated that and also also the
that that part was transformed by you
miranda i mean i thought the mom was
going to be kind of the villain of the
movie i had written it in a way
in my mind she was like the villain of
the movie and then
when you performed her she was just so
vulnerable to her circumstances she was
just trying to be a great mom to her
daughter and that was a discovery for me
and i think
it's one of the like the things that
many i think
yeah i think for a lot of people it's
really one of the more you know she's
the one of the most
um uh the character that you're almost
rooting for
uh as much as madeline basically yeah
um yeah it was so special i just so
blessed that you worked on that thank
you so much
like one of the greatest experiences of
my life seriously
i mean really like yeah
i have a follow-up question there
actually about directing actors
and you know you both you're both actors
and i'm sure that gives you an advantage
you know in directing
other actors but if you could distill
that down into sort of
like what factor there is it gives you
an
advantage being an actor
but being behind the camera too
what do you have a good one for that
just
game well you know it's interesting
because i don't con
you know i never really consider myself
an actor although i have done it and but
i think more than acting i have taken a
[ __ ] ton of acting
classes which i did very purposefully to
become a better director
and actually one point in my 20s it was
because i i was like looking for a
spiritual
path and i was like i was reading about
early christianity and how in early
christianity you know you'd meet in
these like
non-hierarchical groups of eight people
and you would sit down and
leadership would pass and you would you
know pray very intensely
and like it was a lot of like letting
letting god through you and i was like
well acting troops
where you have this consistent group
that you meet with where the leadership
is kind of like moving around and
you're trying to access otherness all
the time feels like one of the more
spiritual places
i would be curious what that's like so i
started i took training with like the
city company in new york
uh i also worked for a long time with
pig iron theater company in philadelphia
and
just because i was so i was interested
in it spiritually of like that
that like releasing yourself and like
becoming something else and then
but also just trying to figure out how
to direct how to talk to actors and
but all of the acting classes that i was
interested in were not like seen study i
never have taken scene study i feel like
i mean i felt like an idiot trying to
direct shirley because
i had never like taken a scene written
on a piece of paper
and i've taken i've taken years worth of
like like weirdo
like clown class and
physical theater and bhuto i had done
this like workshop where you ran and you
sang
it was all acting class you know but it
was um
about kind of like freedom of physical
and vocal expression
as opposed to like learning lives so
uh so trying to direct shirley i just
want to see
i just was like oh my god i'm working
with michael stobart and elizabeth moss
and i
i do not know what to do but they did
they didn't know what to do they had
done it many times so luckily that that
solved that problem um
uh right you know how to do your
thing yeah yes yes i mean i was
drawn to you because of that
weirdness you know it see it actually
seemed safer to me
than to me personally to someone like me
and i know that you've worked with other
people from
who are not in such a clear-cut actor
tradition
you know different kinds of performers
and i think
those people are drawn to you in part
because they feel like you're embracing
it the tradition in such a
broad way you know it's um
so inclusive yeah i don't i actually
think that acting
the acting thing is really useful in
writing
and in sort of knowing
what's important on the day i think um
like i i feel clear
on what lines hold story in them
and can't change and what lines can
change and things like that
but it really actually in terms of
directing
a lot of the time it sort of [ __ ] me up
because
um like on this movie only one actor
could i really direct coming from my
acting place which is probably my
strongest
like i know what i want because i can
feel it in my body
and how i would do it right and then i
have to translate it
into like some simple thing like
why don't you try and hide that
from her or whatever you know which is
like a whole step that's like not
that natural to me but with evan
i could literally just feel it in my
body
what i wanted her not not do a line
reading or
show what i wanted um but just
kind of feel it and like maybe twitch my
head a little and sort of
really in an incoherent ways kind of
half say
something and she'd be like uh-huh and
and then go do this really perfect
like laser sharp you know just what i
had had him wow and you know plus um
plus her own great thing and and i was
like okay this is a once in a lifetime
thing like i it it's not like that does
not i mean
you know deborah winger just look at me
and be like uh
are you trying to talk like you know or
whatever like it's not
it's no one should be expected to be
directed that way
but um uh
yeah anyways so i don't i'm just just
it's just to say that it doesn't
necessarily help you
with your actors because you can't act
the part
um you have to
like kind of do the inverse of that you
have to be the things that they want to
act it
to give room to that you know yeah it's
that's that's all pretty tricky to me
um but it help i mean gosh each one of
the four people in my movie had such
different approaches that it's isn't it
doesn't it become like this
you know three-ring circus or something
when you're like and now
this person needs that and you know it's
yeah
i don't know how you found that because
that's awesome
yeah gina gina is so fun it is really
well it's not only that i mean it's it's
interesting to think about them having
different approaches because they also
just have such different
characters to explore so it almost feels
like a
fit that their approach would be totally
you know that you would have to like
i can't imagine yet directing evan and
then directing gina
you know her like what a different um
performance it was so
yeah yeah yeah gina is like a director
herself
yeah um should we try and do another
question here we go
we have a lot of questions now actually
if you can okay great
i'm gonna move to a slightly um i'm just
my neck is
i did not angle my computer well so i
have a messy bed behind me there we go
great okay
cool you josephine um how did the
production process differ from
madeline's madeline to shirley how did
you handle
the larger production oh wow it was
um that was a felt like a you know it's
funny it felt like a big step up and it
also just
felt the same and that you didn't feel
like you had enough time or
enough research and i was like this is
so much bigger of a movie than i've ever
gotten to make and i still feel like
we're barely gonna get through it i mean
um
madeline's model was the first feature
where there was
an actual crew like my previous two
features had had
i had had you know less than 10 people
on the crew so you have
basically you can shout and everyone can
hear what the
things ever you know what needs to
happen next um
whereas on madeline's medal there are
people outside and there are people in
trucks and then there are people
inside and there's walkie-talkies and it
was so funny because i kept
i had to learn like what it meant to use
your id like that
i'm i kept running around to try to be
like i have to talk to the production
designer where's the production designer
and then
like i can't reach her and then the id
would be like so i have a walkie talkie
like
all you have to just tell me you just
tell me i'm the only person who needs to
communicate with anyone everyone has a
walkie-talkie except you you are the
only one because i would be like
running like i can't find the art
director like with
costumes person like i couldn't and i
was freaking out you know and then
um and he was like just i'm on i
literally
it was that was a learning process and
then yeah that makes it a lot easier
when you do have
you just that that does help to have the
walkie-talkie
um uh but you know actually it was
i think we found crew for surely that
felt like so it felt like that
with that crew it was so much
the they were just so good i mean
everyone was so good
sue chan our production designer used to
be an art director for paul thomas
anderson we had a great script which
helped because that
meant people wanted to do the film you
know um but then
we had uh sterla gravlin who is just
such an insightful and
sweet and very um what's her word like
intimate vulnerable like he just has
this like presence with the actor that's
so special
so it was funny that we ended up
shooting so much of the film handheld i
really didn't think we would do that but
then when we started working together
it it was like i don't know everything
else just felt a little too
stuck in time whereas when we wanted the
film to feel
like there's the reason it's set in 1948
but what's the reason we're shooting it
now and i think that
like that level of presence and kind of
um
staying attuned to the moment um was
something that we were trying to really
access
uh so so i tried not to think too much
about the production and honestly that's
also
i have to shout out to allison carter
who is our one of our producers
um she she can really like hold down the
fort in terms of a production and
and she understood my process she worked
on madeline's madeline and so
she she was able to communicate like how
i work to the departments because i
think that
because this process is a little bit
more it's not exactly like here's the
shot list
and you know we need to do the close-up
here and then we're going to do the wide
crane shot you know it's more like
you know let's like the camera is going
to be a creature you know
it crawls across the room you know so
that she she kind of could
could prep the crew for that way of
working and for the being present to the
moment instead of like
the um shot listing kind of approach i
mean we had a shot list but
a lot of my shot lists are usually like
one
work with ashley connor the dp i would
they were called like ash cam which just
meant
ashley shoots whatever feels like she
should shoot it
you know that's the shots it's like
whatever actually thinks you should
shoot you know it's like a medium
ashley shoots you know and then sterla
we had
we had a kind of um we had different uh
with like five different camera
approaches so
um you know that one was like action
driven by the
by the movement through a room one was
like more floaty and dream like
one was this creature where the camera
is like living close to the body like a
baby and then
if it wants to cross to another person
it has to like go on
go along a table to get to them like go
along a hard surface so the camera can't
just pan it has to like move along the
surface
um so we have these approaches
yeah it was and that was actually really
exciting a way of working that we
developed these approaches and then
and then i just could trust him in the
scene i'd be like okay it's creature
go forth you know whatever field you
know you'll get into the zone and the
actors will get into the zone
and you'll find it together basically
yeah it is so
i mean the way it shot i was just
looking at it and i was kind of like
well
everyone should just watch this movie if
they're trying to figure out how to make
a move like it's so
open so many doors you know like and now
it's just
[ __ ] like luscious you know and it
does exactly that thing you're saying of
it's so
modern like you get the joy of watching
this period thing
but it's so cool like in a
like right at your throat current way
you know like urgent um yeah
definitely [ __ ] me up watching that
while i was editing cajillionaire
i remember starling kind of went and i
went to that screening and she had to
like talk me down from the ledge the
whole
drive home oh
that's sweet it's a very vulnerable
place but yeah it's like
um yeah it's just very special how it's
shot
yeah and all your movies to be honest
are like that's
like one of your super powers it's like
that intimacy with the camera as a
director yeah
thanks question for you miranda from
tony
asking you did an art piece at the
hammer with amy uh
adrian is that involving taping people
and asking
questions what became of that
oh i don't know what i don't recall that
i mean amy adrian was my assistant and
then
went on to be like a great documentary
filmmaker
um but i'm blanking out on what
that was so everyone should just
look into her work
[Laughter]
we are on the hour do you have time to
stick around for like another 10 minutes
or so
to get a few more questions in all right
and can you
yeah yeah yeah that's fine uh kelly
asks both of you uh she's a huge fan of
your work
uh any suggestions for a screenwriter
who keeps receiving advice to just
make something but i'm not really a
director other than in my mind
any practical tips all right
um maybe
so they're saying that because you need
like a calling card of some sort yeah
she doesn't feel she's a
director to direct her material so
right i mean practical tips about
directing
or like what should she do she's just a
screenwriter i mean she would need to
like
have a friend she wanted to work with
her and make
a movie you know yeah i mean that's
legitimate that
uh it is easier to just go out and make
something if you're a director but
as a writer you rely on people reading
your work right to get
right right
it's so funny because sadly like my
advice to everyone is always like just
make something so now i'm like well you
put me on the spot with you
right because you know but the other
thing is i think that
you know it is true so what i will say
is
you know if they're telling you just
make something because you need to get
your voice into the world
and you're like i can't you know or like
i don't have the tools and there's all
these
you know things it's you know i my first
feature i want i wrote this million
dollar
it was like probably 10 million dollar
movie and it was like this fantasy movie
that had like
it was it was not going to i i realized
after about like
i had written it for five years and when
i started trying to raise the money it
was like
this is not going to happen and i'm not
going to get to make this movie and i
was really
sad and then i was like well what can i
make with like three people
in one location you know and then i made
that was smelling lovely and then that
movie got to berlin anyway so just
so i guess you know sometimes the
constraint of
what can you make you're a writer right
so so your brain is your best
you know as your as your your friend and
your ass that it's sort of like
what is the thing that's stopping you
from making something so maybe that's
money or maybe it's like i you know
don't know anybody and it's coveted and
you know i can't shoot anything
but i wonder if there's a way that you
could
you know say what are the two things
that i do have what can
even if it's just an iphone and i have
i have a week you know i have a week and
i have an iphone that maybe there is
something that you can make
um and you might be surprised that
sometimes the constrictions
can be really helpful or if you have two
people who are actor friends
um you know that that's that i think
sometimes
the being forced to do something that
you didn't intend to do that doesn't
seem like
it would work might be surprising um
yeah i just saw um not that long ago
a short film made by a woman totally the
same thing like she's
just wants to be a writer she is a
screenwriter
um so it was just two women and it was
just a conversation between them like it
didn't aspire
to much and initially i was like i'm not
sure this i'm not sure i'm gonna get
through this
but it really was fascinating and it was
fascinating because of
the writing you know and she all she had
to do was get these two good performers
um and it definitely like she is now
someone in my mind who i
think of as a great screenwriter you
know so i guess
in a way yeah just the same thing that
you said but i was like is this can this
actually work and i just checked in my
head and it can
um so yeah also just remind yourself you
don't have to show it to anyone right
there's there's nothing you can't have
that fear of rejection or people
critiquing it just make it for yourself
yeah that's true
um kk for you miranda says uh you should
sell that list
and david for both of you uh says
considering the contrast in your
artistic process
where do you where do each of you think
ideas come from
does finding and holding on to ideas
require that certain conditions
be met
where do ideas come from i think they i
think there are probably certain
conditions that are more ideal for ideas
for each person and i think finding
those conditions i did this amazing
workshop
with this really crazy cool like clown
performer alexandra tatarsky who i think
took this workshop from um uh
this uh i think his name is miguel
miguel gutierrez he's a he's a
performance artist and
but he is so his piece was his the
workshop was like
you take an hour and you make a piece a
one minute piece
and then he asks you like 20 questions
like what did you do first what did you
do next
um what did you not do what did you not
allow yourself to do what is the
opposite of the piece that you made
and then you you answer all these
questions and you sort of slowly realize
like oh okay like the first thing i did
when i was making my pieces
i went outside and i that is actually
how i have
originated almost all of my work i have
to go into nature
i need the quiet time i need i need the
trees like i just need the outdoors
even if it's just literally walking
outside you know if it's if i'm in an
urban environment
so and then um
and then also that you know you can
notice if there's things that in your
process that you don't usually allow
yourself to do
um uh gosh i should i can maybe pull up
those questions and try to
post them in the chat so that you guys
have them if you wanted to give yourself
this workshop
give yourself an hour make a one minute
piece and then answer all these
questions then actually the idea is that
at the end of the workshop
you you do what is the piece you did not
make what did you not allow yourself to
do and then you have to make the
opposite piece
that is like the opposite of the piece
that you made and that is um
like you words that describe your piece
what are the opposite of those words
you have to make a piece that is that
that uses a process you did not
allow yourself to make so it's fun why
am i even talking with this
what you asked what was the question
where yeah it helped me realize that how
much i appreciate nature and also i love
i just love art
i love seeing other art and reading and
and
talking to my friends i love meeting a
person who like is so fascinating that i
feel like i have to make work with them
or about them
i think that's been an inspiration for a
lot of my work yeah
we had a previous panelist on the coffee
talk say that that they found
sort of new ideas and inspiration
not coming to them during the lockdown
because they needed to be outside and
interacting with people
around them yes if you find that if you
have that list sure please yeah yeah
i'll pull it up one more time just
sharing her
yeah i love that you have you've taken
all these workshops
like that like i literally i was like if
i take any workshops i was suddenly just
like
what have i done in my life like
um i mean because you kind of
covered a lot i'll just say also don't
forget to be real
simple and dumb about it like probably
looking at your phone
doesn't help you get ideas you know
generally speaking and um
i hold on one sec let me uh
oh okay i don't have it as readily
available as i thought
um the whole point was that i hide my
nipples so that
blew that line
um but uh i have this box that i lock my
phone in that's a timed
lock box um and i just want to point out
like
before you even can get to the miguel
gutierrez workshop
level of mind you probably need to
like put the phone away you might
like for me when i'm writing um
i write down my dream first thing
every morning and it's not that i'm
gonna use that dream
or that um or anything literal
it's kind of like a a practice it's like
i'm saying
to myself my absolute top
priority is my relationship to my
unconscious
and like so first thing i'm doing even
though it's weirdly involves getting out
my computer like
my eyes are like barely open and i have
to tell my child i haven't written down
my dream yet
please step outside you know like
not like the most warm and fuzzy first
thing to be doing
um and then yeah
they'll call out are you done and i'm
like yes
now i'm done you can come in um and uh
anyways that there are probably some
real basic
things that you know this helps this
doesn't help
you know and like um
i feel like those are the things we
often are like less appealing to listen
to like we want something more
fancy than that but it's actually
pretty basic yeah and walking too i
i i get a lot um from
yeah just walking being in russian uh
there is someone here in the questions
has
said uh that they are willing to read
kelly's script
um so oh yay kelly
we did this what's happening here yeah
gosh this is so crazy i can't
copy and paste all there's 18 questions
and it will not let me
copy and paste them i wonder why wow but
um
uh so as a question from kenny asking
about
for both your rehearsal process and also
kind of preparation in terms of
storyboarding or other pre-visualization
and also hello to josephine
fellow prince tony oh hi hi kenny
that's exciting i love i i love
princeton i went to princeton
now everyone knows
um i have i've written three of the
questions down i'm sorry i'll get to the
other there's like 18. i'll we'll
i'll get it done before you say goodbye
do you want to go first for your process
rehearsal um
process not i don't feel like we both
have to answer all of them so why don't
you answer that one
i know but i really want to know what
your rehearsal process is
because i haven't gotten to be that you
got to see mine but i didn't get to see
yours
i don't but that's because i don't
really
like i did one i can tell you like what
i did with evan
um it doesn't it's not like i have a
thing that i always do
um often i'm just sort of
trying to like uh
spend time together to get a sense of
does anyone have any
really crazy ideas that i need to like
nip in the bun now before we get on set
you know like was planning on doing a
weird accent or you know like
i don't sometimes it's like my standards
are like
kind of that low like let's just get the
lay of the land here are we all
on the same page answer basic questions
what are the relationship
you know if anyone needs a backstory you
know
not um but i will say with evan
um also with deborah on this like they
both had
like had to sort of physically transform
and not
not just like their hair or their
clothes or whatever but like
from on a soul level so with
evan i um
i had i i would sort of talk to her
like like i was a therapist and um
which is crazy like this character
doesn't know anything about therapy so i
would
say first of all like if these questions
make you uncomfortable
just like don't like treat them
as weird as they are um and then i
i'd so we did one round like that her
trying to do that and then i'd say okay
now you can't
use language you just have to use animal
noises
you know to answer these questions and
then
the next round was like you don't even
have that you just have to do it
physically you know so she'd be like
knocking
books off the shelf or whatever and
along with that
like you know we sort of figured out
like you don't gesture with your hands
ever
you don't look people in the eye
a lot but but the real key i think was
like
shrinking down her intellectual space
like she's a full
being a full soul but um she's not
intellectually
um chomping at the bit you know
as far as like the speed of her thoughts
so um
so getting to that space where like
there's not an
output that's easily flowing
um that i think was
like a lot of the rehearsal was to get
that and then once she had that
it was kind of like she could do
anything with it
yeah i don't know
we are pretty much out of time okay uh
i my last question to everyone on these
coffee talks is
just uh what are you watching or reading
any sort of pandemic pics
for our audience could be uh classics
hidden gems
something really obscure feel free to
dig deep
well it's funny because i have watched
very little because um
i've been working trying to get this
feature off the ground and then we have
a baby so every minute that i'm not
working i'm with her so
i i did at the beginning i was i was so
excited i was like oh this is i thought
when we all thought it was gonna be like
three weeks or like a month
right i was like great like i have two
weeks to just and i watched um
uh press burger oh what's this that
press burger and powell paul and press
burger yeah there's
these amazing directing duo they did the
red shoes
and they did um uh um
black narcissus which i had it was
amazing so i saw black narcissus and i
was like i have to see everything that
these guys made
um they made a movie called i know where
i'm going
that is amazing oh really oh good i
haven't gotten there yeah i do not know
where it's going i know where i'm going
good oh i have to watch that um and then
i
also really enjoyed the politician i
watched the politician
i hadn't seen it yet so i watched the
first season and and
a good chunk of the second season yeah
yeah
miranda um
i this is gonna fall in the predictively
obscure
category um but it was the first thing
that popped into my head
because i have a child who's really
obsessed with um
like 3d graphics and animation
and and sort of like creating uh
is using all these sort of um using the
pandemic to become like a
computer gaming artist or something i
don't know
um this child is eight um and so i've
been trying like i don't wanna
expose them to i don't really want them
to be on minecraft all day or so you
know like
um and so i've been just trying to find
other things and i i suddenly remembered
this guy
ian chang um really
pretty mind-blowing artist and he kind
of uses i mean their videos
um so i think they fall within
you know film independent but they're in
galleries
um and they use like gaming
engines um uh
and they're they're really weird and
beautiful and the
like if you know we i've been watching
with my child the
videos of ian chang talking and it's
just really interesting thought
behind them about the relationship
between kind of technology and
and art and humans and um
uh so worth it's all online um and i so
that is literally what i
i think the last thing i watched was was
a bunch of his work yeah
wow i'll have to check those out
we are out of time thank you both thank
you so much
yeah thank you everyone we miss you
i know good luck really
it's time
really appreciate you guys taking the
time it's nice to feel
i do feel your presence even if we can't
see you
it's just so nice to have yeah to be
able to share talk about work
with an audience thank you thank you
paul thank you so much
thank you for taking this thank you
miranda yeah good luck everyone
bye
you